man they sure did go all in on the make
the kids look dirty make up did they dig
that hole with their faces don't worry
it's just a pack of wolves I mean
they'll only tear us limb from limb if
they get any closer but this board game
is super scary so let's continue we see
throughout the film that the game lures
players in with it's hypnotizing drum
beats but why do it now when no one is
around to hear all yours
the kid clearly wrote across when it
said don't walk plus aren't you supposed
to walk your bike across the street
I'm just saying bill should have at
least given Allen a stern talking-to
for all these bullies seriously hiding
out behind the statue in anticipation of
Allen riding by how do they know his
schedule so well this is an absurd
amount of reconnaissance to plan an
otherwise standard nerd beating come on
kid his actual name is Parrish prepare
to perish perish was just sitting there
for you and you completely missed it
cause you should know better than to let
the boy playing human Sam admonishes
Carl for letting Allen play in the
factory after telling Allen the factory
isn't a playground when all Allen is
doing is literally just standing around
and talking just French not anymore so
you're saying she's my girlfriend now
sweet wait why do you still look angry
yeah the Jessup gang proceeds to beat up
Allen outside his father's shoe company
even though they were clearly adults
milling around in the background just
seconds before who could intervene at
any moment I haven't seen this many
negligent adults since I watched all 103
episodes of Teen Mom silly takes off on
Allen's bike but who gets Billy spike
does he just leave it there does one of
the other bullies take it with them that
means there should be a kid in that mix
who's walking two bikes home and I'm not
seeing it Hey look it's a disheveled
bloodied kid casually walking into a
hardhat construction zone guess we
should all just go about our business
then
[Music]
this dude wanted a child dig some sort
of ancient box out of the side of a
construction site but doesn't do or say
about it I guess he's still on his Union
mandated coffee break what was that you
order to of course I heard it besides
the hair color this movie may have set
the record for kids that looked the
least like their eventual adult selves I
found this really weird game in the
factory a game
there was no way that Alan fit that game
into his suitcase especially since he
had all that food stashed in there
before he even packed it all so I
thought Alan was super psyched to run
away and the appearance of Sarah didn't
even deter it but now he's ready to
abandon the entire plan just to play
this game how much hole does this thing
have over him the CEO with money to
munch roll credits
you roll the dice to move your token
doubles gets another turn and the first
player to reach Han wins you want to
play I understand there's some magical
influence here but this sounds like a
boring game the instructions just say to
roll the dice and move you so why would
Alan be so fucking excited about playing
board games five years ago what was
behind Sarah's hilariously specific
board game embargo did she have a
dramatic Candyland incident was there an
ankle injury related to chutes and
ladders these bat holes wait to attack
simmer until after Alan's turn and after
he's sucked into the game probably
because they've been trained in
cinematic timing yeah they're terrifying
and definitely a nuisance but these bats
aren't doing jack to Sarah
except flying around maybe they're
trying to teach her about becoming a
symbol of hope to a crime riddled city
or something like that damn it Lily you
just showed the year on the first two
time periods but now you're expecting me
to do math and figure out what the data
is I was told there would be no fucking
math I'll have to get a locksmith out
for this one spooky mansion comes
complete with it's very own locked
mystery door that the realtor lady just
didn't feel the need to unlock or break
down herself before selling it to
somebody I'm going to Motel sex this is
Tom Beaudette and we'll leave the
product placement on for you that's an
African bat some kids said she saw a
bunch of those back in the sixties
really moving 26 years later in a random
expositional exterminator happens to
remember some kids saying she saw the
same kind of bat what's worse is that
it's not even exposition we need also
how does a kid scared out of his mind
give detailed enough information to
identify the species of a winged
creature of death that came after the
let alone two kids 26 years apart also
if the bat that Peter saw was one of the
ones Sarah saw back in 1969 how is that
bat still alive 26 years later do all
the animals that come out
we lived forever do they have the
ability to reproduce that's on I worry
about a literally bat enthusiast in
scary attic with two underage children
feels the need to up the creep factor
211 by telling the story of another
minor who was murdered and dismembered
and probably buried somewhere in the
house because who doesn't love
frightening children Lilith was able to
get this place in tip-top shape by
herself within a day notice how a
monopoly is at the bottom of the other
stack
that's because Monopoly much like
Jumanji tears people's lives apart back
in 1869 they had to bury the out of this
game to prevent it from endangering
anyone else but it's been hanging out up
here for 26 years without any problem
until now sure it's a cool box but
there's no way the kids would know that
this game is the source of the drumming
noise that terrified the mere moments
ago it's gotta be microchips or
something yes the progress of Technology
joke is cute but how exactly would
microchips do this it's clearly
magnetics whether you're a kid from the
60s or 90s and learned it from mr.
wizard or mr. Nye the Science Guy we all
know this be magnets how did they know
to look for information from the magic
green circle there was no reason for
them to be leaning in here or really to
assume anything is about to happen those
mosquitoes are the size of birds if the
bats are genuine African bats and later
we see other real animals why do the
mosquitoes get the growth hormones when
the others don't
Judy Knox one mosquito out the window
and the other two mosquitoes follow
mosquitoes aren't hive mind insects they
just kind of do their own thing why do
the two mosquitoes follow the first one
out the window when there are two easy
targets standing right in front of them
this will not be an easy mission monk
you slow the expedition why does he grab
the dice here I'm guessing there's some
BS story reason he needs to have them
but why in this instance of monkey panic
would he think he would need them with
him also all the other times the players
roll the dice something's happened to
them but on Peters turn the monkey show
up in the kitchen sure they eventually
go down there to check out that noise
but basically they could have kept
playing upstairs with little consequence
Jesus Christ these murderous marauding
monkeys man wait let me get this
straight he grabbed the dice so that 60
seconds later they could look at them
and remember they were playing a game I
know I send the dice grabbing once but
here's another sin for having such an
unnecessary and flimsy reason I didn't
see this part and apparently no one else
did either by the Judy Peter Alan and
Sarah not look at the only other written
text on this game that's not like there
was a 40 page instruction manual
instructions say if we finish the game
it'll all go away
we've only had mosquitos and monkeys so
far why not stop the game here before it
gets worse unless the animals are
completely indestructible and pervious
to animal control monkeys and a few
giant mosquitoes seem pretty easy to
manage right sure later on we discovered
the mosquitos are making people sick but
duty doesn't know that it takes movie
nearly 30 minutes to finally Mork mom
and dad this house has been empty for
years wait this isn't a big leg
situation where Alan wakes up as a grown
man he's been living inside the game for
26 years I could clearly note the
passage of time sure he'd be looking for
his parents when he came back but he
would totally know that it's been a long
while since he left
looks like Alan never outgrew his
running out into a busy street without
looking habit when it comes to the
monkey CGI in this movie I'm guessing
the CG stands for a complete garbage
also is this a standard police procedure
for shotgun storage loaded safety off
and vertically stored this is to fight
off all those sudden car top killers
I've been hearing about Aunt Nora seemed
to think the theists town to ever exist
is the perfect place for her bed and
breakfast when his kid ran away Sam put
everything you had into trying to find
him I don't think anybody loved his boy
more than Sam did random homeless dude
is extremely knowledgeable about the
family dynamic between Sam and Alan the
parish is still around I see him now and
then they're over on Adams Street I
really hope this quarter clarified off
screen that Alan's parents are actually
in the cemetery on Adams Street because
if you didn't then that's a dick move
sir
ooh nice boots mrs. Thomas but don't you
want something a little comfier for the
ambulance ride that's more like it is
Alan the seasoned vet at fighting all
the creatures in the game Laura see this
comic relief he was a badass when facing
down the lion earlier but now he's
freaked out about a fucking bug realtor
ladies car keys were left in the
ignition and her car in the middle of
the road the guys in the ambulance call
for any kind of backup to get the wreck
cleared away or do a few giant
mosquitoes get the same martial law
treatment as a zombie apocalypse
yeah but what happened to the giant
mosquito that was locked in the
windshield it just flew away after being
previously obsessed with biting these
assholes even though there's a literal
lion somewhere in the house Alan and
therefore movie has time for this whoa
did they have a barber training course
and Alan's jungle coz that's a pretty
stellar self cut I've seen things you've
only seen in your nightmares
ah so Alan saw an early cut a
Bicentennial man it's not my time this
turn is it Sarah Whittle so let me get
this straight
with one roll of the dice Alan lost 26
years of his life but Sarah just got
briefly chased by a few bats that lived
a fairly normal life traumatized life
but what happened to the bats I didn't
put anyone else in town this place gives
me the creeps said Peter staring up at
what was probably the nicest looking
house in the neighborhood you killed her
character gets shocking news and
immediately passes out cliche well he
really feels like this was a 90s thing
doesn't it look I know that they've got
to have Sally to play the game but did
they really need to kidnap her from her
own home also sure it was shocking for
her to see how alive but they didn't
drug her right she stayed passed out on
this entire trip back to the parish
house my father could barely hug me let
alone company into pieces not quite sure
your syllogism is valid since you're a
presupposition of fathers who don't hug
don't dismember is likely untrue we
started playing a little game now just a
few minutes ago Alan was lecturing the
kids about how dangerous this game is
how impossible it is to win but now he
tracked down Sarah kidnaps her and
forces her to play the game Jesus this
movie's unexpectedly dark did I miss a
plum house logo at the beginning of this
movie harvest time
wait that's it they just had to free
Peter from the one pod and the vine
system to get out of the immediate
danger
what the hell are the actual rules for
this game and one role you can get just
a brief but ultimately harmless
vegetation attack and in the next one
you're banished to the jungle for 26
years oh my god I won this Karl been
looking for his crusier
Alan and the kids have gone to the
factory discovered his parents are dead
still in a car taking a nap went through
the lecture about how dangerous this is
went to find Sarah kidnapped her and
then fought the magical vine but Carl's
just now finding his car okay I'll buy
that nobody's heard the monkeys in the
lion messing around inside but no one
hears it reports these gunshots I take
Carl driving up to the scene for anyone
to recognize what's going on Carl gets
in his car and drives away without
securing the area calling for backup or
calling in the report of a strangely
dressed dude destroying his cruiser with
a very large gun in a residential
neighborhood
we wouldn't has called me crazy ever
since I told the cops that you were
sucked into a board game so you changed
your last name and didn't leave town and
didn't change houses either and while
we're headed are you even a real psychic
if you are surely you would have
predicted this Andy didn't in addition
to training at Juilliard robin williams
attended the prometheus school of
running away from things now anyone asks
you didn't get this here you're not a
postal worker are you and some of these
jokes have really not aged well so Alan
tracked this bird based on just knowing
it would go towards water and he somehow
found it this quickly and there was
absolutely nothing wild about that goose
chase a pelican chase or African Pelican
thing chase okay fine maybe living in
the jungle 26 years taught you this
skill but convenient fish is still
convenient so how did this four survive
as a kid inside the Jumanji jungle this
kid gets beat up by sixth graders chance
did he have against all the creatures
that live inside the game let's go have
we had any indication of this sudden
dynamic between Alan and Peter I mean I
guess he's supposed to be a father
figure that didn't have a good enough
example or something but this is totally
manufactured considering they've been
essentially equals in this movie so far
every time there's trouble I remain to
you I don't know what you're talking
about all right I'm taking you away
forever eat I'm
you mean like the two times because
currently there is a much trouble going
on and neither are those times had
anything to do with anything Alan did
how are these animals still stampeding
together I mean not sure of the ground
speed velocity of an African zebra but
I'm guessing it's not the same as the
elephants and rhinos with or without
coconuts
monkey Peter survives this VanPelt
strides purposely toward the sir
sav-a-lot light this is all part of the
plant even though he's new to town and
from a very different time period
entirely and the building offers no
clear advantage to what he's trying to
accomplish this works now what are we
gonna do
why officer Carl here just let you go
and was on your side what on earth is
there to gain from locking him to his
car goddammit not only are these fucking
monkeys able to operate the clutch of
this motorcycle despite none of them
being able to reach it they've also
figured out how to operate the siren
these monkeys and the bike they wrote in
on serie and the kids are able to pull
off this home alone style trap for Van
Pelt
despite zero communication with each
other also this is a moderately sized
department store and they're being
tracked by an experienced big-game
hunter but whatever bring on the prat
balls I could've shot you at any moment
then why didn't you you didn't roll the
dice monkeys are screwing with everyone
that Peters the one that rolled them the
giant mosquitoes didn't seem to care who
they were stinging Judy rolled the
Stampede and it's hang up home town
there is no reason for Van Pelt to have
such a huge killing boner for Alan ah
remember the 90s when we all thought
things chaotically crashing into lots of
other things was hilarious and exciting
yeah me neither
how do you escape certain death when
you've painted yourself into a corner a
latex machina of course where's Peter
[Music]
great really I mean giving the amount of
crazy that's happened this is arguably
the best case scenario Peter just has
some extra hair for the moment and all
they have to do is finish the game to
reverse it
[Music]
why would you get out of the car all
right another lazy setup for a not funny
gag involving a monkey also you know for
a stampede these animals are really good
about staying on the road we're gonna go
in here we're gonna finish that cake is
there some rule that they have to play
the game in the same location this game
has more unexplained rules than that
special room at my grandma's house I'm
not saying this magical vine couldn't
compact this police cruiser like this
I'm just saying why would it want to and
also that it couldn't every month at the
quarter moon there'll be a monsoon in
your Lagoon that's less of a riddle and
more like a straight-up there's a
monsoon coming this is what happens when
you let the writers assistants take the
wheel Jumanji can I ask why these idiots
keep waiting for the consequences to
show up before rolling again I feel like
if they just rolled one after another
they could have been finished before the
first drop hit the ground king hell man
the game promised a monsoon not a mutant
crocodile everything else has been
extremely specific about the threat hang
on the Stampede basically takes out an
entire wall of this home earlier how did
this water even collect Oh looky here
did the game manifest a helpful
stagehand Alan you wrestled an alligator
for me it's a crocodile alligators don't
have that little fringe and link rather
than kiss the love interest Alan chooses
demands playing the difference between
alligators and crocodiles also Alan will
be excellent at cinemasins
despite the water being everywhere in
the house this room is bone dry never
thought I'd find the effects in flubber
to be fantastically realistic but
compared to this it's a masterpiece but
why are they giant make up your mind
game actual animals or monster versions
this ax gag was actually pretty clever
so please Peter monkey tail ruin it by
breaking the fourth wall thanks geez he
just sunk into the floor below why
didn't he just fall all the way through
the quicksand then sure it'd be a pretty
high drop but it's better than getting
stuck in the fucking floorboards
considering the amount of hair on these
hands I guess Alan was also cursed with
the monkey virus
Van Pelt's coat of many colors makes
sense unless you remember that paint is
not pre-mixed all of that paint that
fell on him should have appeared white
as Alan makes his final roll now is as
good a time as any to recognize exactly
how little this movie has cared about
game continuity in fact I actually rode
a 917 word detailed diatribe listing 23
cases of game board mistakes pieces
moving backwards on the wrong spaces
jumping to other players tracks and not
adding up
including the fact that this three that
Alan just rolled will only get him
within six spaces of the finish at best
but instead of putting you through all
that piers to one
three sins plus 15 for the time I spent
on it and another 25 because any and all
of it would have been super easy to keep
track of you lazy mathematically
challenged slapstick loving continuity
shunning holes of asses isn't this
bullet a real-world bullet I with the
game pull it back in yes I know the game
is reversing all the consequences but
it's only pulling back the things that
released in the accurate version Alan
takes the bullet to the head Sarah
screams a nightmarish scream but they
both still wake up in 1959 just a tad
bit more traumatized oh great gravy on
mashed potato Mountain time travel if
you can't even handle the rules of its
own game let alone the complexity that
goes along with resetting a time line
gone five minutes five minutes hope this
is a terrible estimation on Sam's part
because even before getting sucked into
the game Alan had time to finish his
meal and pack all the things to prepare
to run away talk to Sarah at the door
and start playing the game which would
take much longer
holy smokes Alan they're not there how
does she know without going up to the
attic to check game can literally reset
time and counter people and animals out
of thin air surely transporting Judy and
Peter to 1969 isn't outside the realm of
possibility here just go freaking look
to be sure jeez kids say hi to mr. mrs.
perish in the original timeline the kids
moved to this small town because their
parents died in Canada but how did they
end up here in this timeline it's not
like Alan could reverse-engineer their
origins he didn't even know their last
name there gonna be a debate now about
whether or not Jumanji is a Christmas
movie because I'm sick of that die hard
I swear to God if Dwayne Johnson isn't
wearing a beret and eating croissants at
a sequel I'm calling bull
so same buddy wanna play Parcheesi good
why don't you live in it I did I
wouldn't be Who I am today if it weren't
for my years there but I don't want your
life
how about Peter and I play and you just
sort of watch thanks I've seen it this
is not a democracy
it's a Qi rock receipt oh yeah beautiful
don't touch the purple means to shoot
poisonous Barb's watch out they spit
sink into the floor
smile my boy sunrise the price is wrong
bitch
because